foreign
George is the host of one of the Ramsey
networks Productions called a podcast
called fine print and one of the very
first episodes in the first season of
fine print George pretty much exposed
turgo Turbo Tax as lying
when they said that they were letting
you file your taxes for free George it
appears you have stirred up a problem I
was a fortune teller a prophet no I
think I think you uh I think you stirred
up something I think someone at the
Federal Trade Commission was listening
that's right the Federal Trade
Commission clearly is a big fan of the
fine print and here's proof here's a
headline the FTC sues Turbo Tax to stop
misleading ads for free tax prep
software
wow the Federal Trade Commission said
Tuesday that into its ubiquitous
advertising claiming its Turbo Tax Prep
software is free to use is misleading
kind of what George said
and has asked a federal court to order
into it to stop disseminating the
deceptive claim that consumers can file
their taxes for free using TurboTax
according to commission the adds some of
which have consisted almost entirely of
the word free spoke spoken repeatedly
mislead people into believing they can
file their taxes for free with TurboTax
in fact most tax filers can't use the
company's free service because it's not
available to millions of taxpayers
such as those who get a 1099
for work in the gig economy or who earn
farm income the agency said in a press
release the FTC said in 2020
approximately two-thirds of tax filers
could not use turbo tax's free product
thus it's not free I added that last
part yeah how this is how this works
right yep and uh you know back when we
did this fine print episode this was
back in March 2021 and we sat down me
and you Dave and we went through their
investor day report and it was their
entire strategy about how they're going
to turn their billion dollar company
into a bajillion dollar Company by
becoming one of the biggest lenders out
there they're trying to sell you on debt
and so they lure you in with this
promise of free they end up charging you
because you needed one extra form and
all of a sudden you're you know three
hours in and they go well that'll be 60
bucks that you thought was free and then
later down the road they use all of your
data points to then sell you debt
through all their partners and providers
down the line so all in all not a great
company
turns out into its Turbo Tax is
even when it's free is basically a lead
magnet for
debt products they're Gathering your
data to sell your debt and that's why
that's what they're doing they're using
it to collect that in other words you're
being manipulated in addition to being
misled you are the product that's what
it comes down to
so if you if you needed more ammo here
you can go listen to the whole fine
print episode it's a short one it's
about 20 minutes long or so and we me
and Dave we unpacked their strategy we
talk to some experts we hear some
stories about people who use Turbo Tax
and got screwed and uh the episode's
called how Turbo Tax is screwing you so
I feel like that was pretty apt I think
you uh I really do think somebody at the
FTC was listening to you I hope they're
fans
um I mean I don't want anything with a
with the you know the acronym coming
after us the IRS the FTC these are scary
people I don't want them on my bad side
the DEA the DEA why are they all three
letters where is this coming from the
FBI the ATF oh we don't need any of
these people yes run three letter CIA we
don't want the CIA no no it keeps going
wow three little three-letter Federal
acronyms not good no and yeah Turbo Tax
has been hammered the last few years pro
publica did a huge piece on them about
misleading this even you know Hassan
Patriot acted a whole episode about how
Turbo Tax is hurting people through this
exact thing so I'm glad someone's
finally going after them more
importantly George Campbell did it on
the fine print that's right I'm just
saying that's the one America remembers
into it said in a statement that it will
vigorously challenge the ftc's complaint
claiming arguments are not credible
I think millions of Americans would
disagree with that
so I think it's easy to say they're
credible